c'est une séquence que nous appelons des
cartes zombies nous avons une grande séquence d'action je
me déroule ici nous avons sept cartes qui
tombent de la structure de stationnement et
chacune d'elles vise un moteur
ici nous devons tirer ces voitures à à  une
vitesse exacte et nous faisons cela en utilisant
le treuil sur la grue chaque chariot
sort successivement pour atterrir sur les
véhicules sur la route ici évidemment
il n'y a personne dedans car ils sont
sur le point d'être empalés 3 000 livres de pelouse
nous font tous mal  environ 35 à 40 voitures dans cet
empilement
c'est comme ça que nous faisons les choses sont rapidement
encouragés à faire des choses pratiques
tant que nous le faisons en toute sécurité c'est beaucoup à
moi
cette action ne ressemble à rien de ce que vous avez
jamais vu ça va être un
carnage total spectaculaire nous '  vous verrez le
résultat très très bientôt